je laisse nos invités s'installer
peut-être vous dire
avant de leur donner la parole que
l'audition de ce matin est retransmise
sur le en direct sur le site internet du
Sénat
et que cette édition a été proposée
d'ailleurs par nos collègues
présidents notre collègue du Rhin et
Madame de La Gontrie excusez-moi j'ai dû
commencer par Madame de La Gontrie
l'année des marmas
et donc naturellement la pensée que
cette idée était intéressante compte
tenu du rapport que vous avez commis
alors certes c'est un rapport qui avait
été qui faisait suite une mission qui
vous était confiée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur de garde des sons en 2021
c'est un rapport qui date donc de
juillet 2021 mais il est évidemment
d'actualité puisqu'il a été rendu public
il y a quelques mois seulement il est
intéressant pour nous messieurs d'en
avoir connaissance bien sûr puisque sa
problématique est connexe à certains de
nos travaux et je pense notamment à se
relatif à la police judiciaire qui est
actuellement en cours et la formation
initiale est continue des forces de
police et de gendarmerie
et c'est aussi un complément utile au
débat que nous avons eu sur la loopmie
et qui a été adopté bien sûr récemment
l'accusation de discrimination est on le
sait souvent brandi par certains pour
mettre en cause la légitimité de
l'action de la légitimité pardon de
l'action des forces de sécurité
intérieure la discrimination dont font
l'objet les agents des forces de police
et de gendarmerie est en retour plus
souvent éludée alors qu'elle est aussi
réelle or l'un des mérites il n'y en a
pas qu'un il y en a plusieurs
naturellement de l'étude que vous avez
menée messieurs avec l'assistance de
plusieurs corps d'inspection d'ailleurs
et d'une part d'avoir une approche
globale de la discrimination dans le
contexte de l'action mené au quotidien
par les forces de l'ordre en abordant à
la fois la question de la discrimination
qui peut être causée par certains de
leurs membres mais aussi de la
discrimination dans leur monde peuvent
être eux-mêmes les victimes soit dans
l'institution policière elle-même
soit de la part de tiers donc vous avez
abordé vraiment la problématique dans
toutes ces formes si je puis dire en
tous les cas sous toutes ses composantes
un autre mérite et d'autre part de
placer cette approche dans le lien
qu'entretienne les citoyens avec les
femmes et les hommes que la charge de
nous protéger au quotidien un lien qui
nous en sommes tous témoins et pour une
partie de la population empreint d'une
grande méfiance que le sentiment d'une
discrimination que certains se plaisent
à présenter comme systémique ne fait
d'ailleurs catiser en termes de vos
travaux vous avez formulé une
cinquantaine de propositions dont un
certain nombre d'entre elles sont
extrêmement opérationnels voilà vous
venez ce matin détailler ces
propositions et présenter ce rapport je
vais naturellement vous laisser
immédiatement la parole tout en vous
remerciant d'avoir accepté de venir
devant notre commission pour faire état
de ses travaux et finalement nourrir
notre propre travail notre propre
réflexion merci
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci de nous avoir invité
Florian Roussel et moi c'est toujours un
honneur d'être entendu par le Sénat
je vais vous parler donc de ce rapport
la lutte contre les discriminations dans
l'action des forces de sécurité en vous
disant tout de suite que nous
n'engageons que nous c'est la liberté
d'un rapporteur à qui une mission est
confiée et qui remet un document à
l'autorité politique qui en fait ce
qu'elle estime de voir en fait ou de pas
en faire mais nous avons écrit ce
rapport avec nos examens et nos
investigations y compris sur le terrain
dans différents endroits de France et
avec nos notre liberté et parfois nos
convictions donc ça plaît ou ça plaît
pas ça intéresse ou pas le produit est
livré et ensuite l'autorité prend ses
responsabilités on entend souvent dire
que les rapports
administratifs ne servent à rien si j'en
étais convaincu j'aurais pas accepté la
mission c'est la deuxième mission que
nous faisons ensemble des problèmes sur
Roussel et moi la précédente sur les
suites de la loi sur la transformation
de la fonction publique de 2019 à nous
avons étudié la manière de mettre en
place la négociation collective dans le
respect du statut et ça a été suivi
d'une ordonnance et peut-être de
d'accord collectif donc là le tandem
c'est reconstitué pour traiter de la
discrimination je constate que dans le
paragraphe 2 5 3 du rapport sur la Love
Me c'est me permettait l'expression
j'aime pas les acronymes enfin je peux
pour aller plus vite
quand même qui porte l'expression
renforcer la lutte contre les
discriminations et moi qui est passé
quelques années au ministère d'intérieur
et au ministère de la Justice je sais
qu'une phrase comme ça ne court pas
absolument les rues dans l'histoire des
textes de en tout cas du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc ça me réjouit de voir
que la loi le Parlement adopte un
document qui reprend ce terme qui n'est
pas neutre qui quelquefois pose de
questions de la part des agents et dans
le paragraphe on voit des mentions qui
sont encore plus rares quand on regarde
l'histoire longue de la sécurité en
France la lutte contre le racisme
antisémitisme la haine anti LGBT et tout
type de discrimination c'est des mots
sont comptés et c'est dans un rapport
annexé à la loi que vous avez adoptée je
constate aussi que le rapport mentionne
un ministère qui doit ressembler à la
population alors là il y a un sujet que
j'ai pas le temps de développer mais qui
est à mon sens tout à fait essentiel
presque de nature constitutionnelle
puisque l'article 74 a avancé pour les
collectivités d'outre-mer un droit de
recruter en fonction de critères de la
population il y a toute une tradition
française auquel je suis attaché qui dit
le contraire qui dit le concours c'est
neutre et donc l'idée que je partage que
je partage et qui est dans le rapport de
faire attention aux dissociations
totales entre le visage d'une police et
la population à mon sens est une
décision courageuse que j'avais pas lu
beaucoup jusqu'à maintenant il y a
quelques années j'étais au balcon d'un
hôtel de Mexico et je regardais j'ose
pas dire en expert mais en tout cas en
personne intéressée l'arrêt d'une
manifestation sur une grande autoroute
occupée par des manifestants la totalité
quasi-totalité des manifestants et le
type en daim c'était pas le type
argentin blanc et les policiers étaient
à 100% type en daim aussi ça faisait
réfléchir sur ce cette problématique que
vous avez mis dans dans la loi je
constate aussi que il y a eu un
changement à la tête des deux
inspections générales de la police
nationale et de la gendarmerie nationale
nous de proposions pas de mettre des
magistrats à la tête ou comme adjoint
dans les inspections générales mais nous
proposons
de d'ouvrir ces inspections pour qu'il y
ait des professionnels de différents
ordres en matière de sécurité peut-être
plus qu'ailleurs la diversité pas
seulement d'origine mais aussi de
professionnels apportent quelque chose
pour la vérité et les forces de sécurité
ont un devoir de vérité j'y reviendrai
nous constatons aussi que plusieurs
mesures que nous proposions sont plus ou
moins déjà notre rapport vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président date de deux ans
donc les choses ont tourné le
spectacle général de la gendarmerie me
rappelait que nos propositions 2 dis
sont 16 17 22 28 sont plus ou moins déjà
mises en oeuvre ou à l'étude donc je le
souhaite comme tout rapporteur que les
nos propositions ne restent pas à l'être
mortes la discrimination c'est selon
l'article 225-1 du code de pénal
atteinte à la dignité de la personne je
retiens bien ce mot dignité et
porte sur l'interdiction de traitement
fondé uniquement sur des critères que
vous connaissez depuis
l'apparence physique jusque à la prétend
du race comme dit la loi maintenant
évidemment la discrimination est révélée
par des traitements défavorables mais le
fait que la définition même ne porte pas
le mot défavorable peut faire réfléchir
perd des traitements à la limite même
favorable qui pourrait être discriminées
on peut y réfléchir je ne développe pas
il faut comprendre le rapport dans un
contexte
qui n'est pas neutre et qu'il faut avoir
en tête dès 1985 la revue sociologique
du travail consacré un numéro spécial à
la police et en étudiant ces process en
1989 j'avais l'honneur sur l'autorité
Pierre Joxe de contribuer à la création
de l'Institut des hautes études de
sécurité intérieure qui faisaient entrer
la recherche dans le monde de sécurité
et qui a prospéré sous des tous les
gouvernements
jusqu'à sa suppression il y a trois ans
et son remplacement par l'ie.m.i du
ministère de l'Intérieur je souhaite
ardemment que cette présence de la
recherche continue et puis
le terrain que nous avons labouré
justement par un rapport de l'IHESI de
1991 le rapport du sociologue vivorka
sur polys et racisme
nous prétendons pas arriver dans un
terrain non du tout exploré donc il y a
toute une série de travaux qui ont mis
en alerte sur la nécessité absolue de
proscrire le racine dans les forces de
sécurité alors le paysage je dis un peu
le contexte et puis très rapidement on
reprendra les mesures mais vous les avez
sous les yeux par contre le contexte
mérite peut-être qu'on s'y arrête un
instant il me semble que depuis bien des
années le pays en matière de sécurité et
de devoir de la sécurité le rapport m'a
été confié parce que je suis déontologue
ministériel au sens de la loi Sapin de
2016 du ministère d'intérieur donc il y
a un lien entre cet aspect et le devoir
déontologie repris dans le code police
gendarmerie 2014
or en observant l'action des forces de
sécurité depuis longtemps il me semble
qu'on est partagé entre trois tendances
que nous avons bien connu au cours de ce
travail premièrement la célébration des
forces de sécurité j'ai pas le temps de
le citer mais je l'ai dans la main mon
texte fétiche c'est un texte d'un
sénateur pas n'importe lequel puisqu'il
s'agit de Pierre valdec Rousseau qui a
préfacé en 1896 un très beau livre sur
l'histoire du corps des gardiens de la
paix et une préface lumineuse que je
recommande à toutes et à tous de lire
sur Le Devoir
l'ingratitude de la population auprès
des gardiens de la paix et la mission
complètement diverse des forces de
sécurité qui ont à traiter des questions
totalement étrangères y compris le
maniement des foules ce qui fait
référence au maintien de l'ordre pierre
vadecrosso 1896
donc la célébration et le comme on
applaudissait les forces de sécurité
après les attentats il y a un premier
mouvement qui sait ce que la nation doit
aux forces de sécurité
la deuxième tendance à l'inverse et
chacun de nous est un peu partagé selon
les événements c'est l'accusation
j'en ai deux exemples qui que qui ne
quittent pas ma bibliothèque parce que
c'est des alertes auxquels il faut
penser l'ouvrage de Mediapart ne parlait
pas de violences policières sous-entendu
parlez-en beaucoup et le petit opuscule
de l'avocat William Bourdon violence
policière il y a tout un courant
dénonciateur qui dit aussi des vérités
qui font prendre en compte sinon nous
aurez pas demandé ce rapport et puis
mais un accusation
il m'arrive de penser toujours à ce que
waldeck-rousse disait dans la fin de son
artiste ici tu es les policiers tués
auxquels il était rendu hommage dans
l'ouvrage il se trouve que il y a 15
jours je traversais Romorantin moi je
suis un adepte de ce que disent les
monuments aux morts et au monument aux
morts de Romorantin côté des tués de la
guerre il y a un hommage à au gardien de
la paix Alphonse Robin tué en 44 à Jean
cruchet était tué dans son service en
1973 et à Xavier juglet dont nous est
pas inconnus abattu sur les
Champs-Élysées parce qu'il était
policier et seulement parce qu'il
portait l'uniforme donc je n'oublie pas
le le
prix du sang chez la dans la police
nationale et la gendarmerie nationale au
rythme de 8 à 10 tombé
chaque année
il empêche que quand il y a des
accusations de violence ou de
discrimination il faut y répondre et
troisième tendance j'espère qu'elle est
la plus répandue c'est la réflexion
l'observation là je renvoie à une autre
de mes Bibles le droit de la police qui
a pris maintenant en quelques années de
de Jacques buisson qui est à la fois
professeur d'universitaire ancien membre
de la Cour de cassation et ancien
directeur de l'école de la police
nationale ça fait quelques qualités pour
observer la la police ou bien je me
permets de citer mon propre ouvrage du
juste exercice de la force il y a trois
ans où je parle des sujets qui vous
intéressent et sur le contrôle de la de
la police alors le cette c'est une
occasion
unique qui nous est donnée par si j'ose
dire 4 ministres puisqu'une première
lettre de mission nous avait été donnée
par Monsieur Castaner et Madame de
juillet 2020 puis ensuite les deux
ministres successeurs messieurs Darmanin
et Dupont-Moretti nous ont confirmés à
la fin de l'année
2020 cette mission
en premier lieu il est clair que
ce rapport a été fait que par de
missionnaires qui croient que en
abordant les difficultés dans la police
dans la grandit quand aisant les
difficultés y compris l'effet de
discrimination on prend des risques pour
la police elle-même et pour la nation
donc notre ligne c'est d'appeler les
choses par leur nom oui il y a de l'Asie
de discrimination dans la police la
question et comment la déceler et
comment la traiter en deuxième lieu
le
n'oublions pas que l'article 12 du code
de procédure pénale dit que la
judiciaire est exercé sous la direction
du procureur et que l'article 15-2 du
code de procédure pénale prévoit des
inspections conjoines justice police
quand un officier de police judiciaire a
un comportement administratif
problématique
donc nous avons voulu associer c'était
une chose que j'avais demandé avant de
prendre la mission d'être missionné par
les deux ministères et pas par le
ministère de l'Intérieur seulement une
histoire là aussi en troisième lieu
nous avons voulu et et en discutant le
projet de lettre de mission nous sommes
allés dans ce sens nous avons voulu
traiter des discriminations commises et
des discriminations subies par la police
nationale il faut avoir discuté avec
certains nous l'avons fait avec des
équipes de police de Marseille y compris
des policiers appartenant à des
minorités visibles qui sont accusées de
servir le pouvoir blanc et il y a il
faut prendre en considération ces choses
qui sont aussi des des troisième
c'était mon troisième point et puis en
quatrième lieu
nous avons voulu mener nos
investigations sur des documents et des
entretiens mais aussi aller sur le
terrain nous sommes allés en plusieurs
endroits Marseille Lille etc
passer des journées avec des forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain
je peux pas jurer que c'était nos
investigations sur le terrain étaient
absolument naturel j'ai souvenir d'une
visite à la gare de Sarcelles pour avec
une délégation la gare de Sarcelles
était à peu près comme si il y avait eu
un attentat il y avait il nous avait
entouré d'un nombre de policiers qui
faisaient que pour parler un vendeur à
la sauvette ou autre il fallait
traverser trois rangs policiers donc je
ne surestime pas la vérité des
instigations mais on sent quand même des
petites choses y compris par ce qu'on ne
vous montre pas
alors
le rapport ils sont son objet est de
nommer les questions par les mots justes
quand on commence à parler de la
discrimination c'est qu'on prend
conscience qu'elle est là
et nous avons travaillé sous le sous le
la houlette de
ce petit objet qui est la Déclaration
des Droits et du citoyen et de son
article 12 la force publique n'a de sens
que pour défendre des libertés alors
nous avons nous sommes allés rencontrer
les policiers et les gendarmes avec ça à
la main
le il est très important d'employer les
bons mots c'est ce que nous essayons de
dire dans ce rapport il y a plusieurs
années que je me bats contre le concept
de chêne pénal utilisé à tout à tout
bout de champ comme si le ce que le
ministre appelle le continent qui
pourrait faire l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions c'est pas l'objet mais que
l'action de maintien de la paix publique
parce que c'est ça qu'il s'agit était
une série de Mayons ayant le même sens
et la même dimension rien ne ressemble
plus à un maillon qu'à un autre or
l'investigation policière le déferlement
au juge et la mise en oeuvre de la
sanction par l'administration
pénitentiaire ou pas c'est pas du tout
une série de Mayons la justice n'est pas
dans le même du tout dans le même
rapport à la police que la police à la
pénitentiaire ou que la police à la
justice donc
nous faisons attention aux mots et
[Musique]
ce que j'appellerai le savoir vrai nous
développons beaucoup dans notre rapport
la manière dont les statistiques sont
faites
comment elles sont classées et donc
c'est très important c'est la
proposition 10 de développer la
recherche et le rapport à la science la
justice le fait le fait pas mal en ayant
renforcé son son potentiel de de
recherche
avec
la mission en recherche Droit et Justice
et l'Institut de recherche de la justice
je souhaite et c'est une des
propositions de du rapport que le
ministère de l'Intérieur seul ou avec la
justice développe ce contact avec les
chercheurs d'une manière d'aérer et de
prévenir des pépins nous
défendons les enquêtes de victimes qui
étaient faites par l'omdrp maintenant
sont prises directement par le système
de recherche du ministère de l'Intérieur
la victimisation c'est la perception des
infractions elles aident beaucoup à
comprendre la sous-estimation des
problèmes que nous avions en charge de
traiter discrimination sont peu
nombreuses dans en tant que infraction
saisie par les systèmes de l'Intérieur à
fortiori par les systèmes de justice ça
veut pas dire qu'elle n'existe pas et
pour comprendre ce décalage les enquêtes
de victimisation sont à développer c'est
notre proposition 26 et puis
l'Observatoire de la discrimination que
nous proposons Florian Roussel va y
revenir donc ces efforts de statistiques
nous avons et nous avons
regardé les nattances la nature des
infractions poursuivies dans les
statistiques de la justice ou la
discrimination est dure à examiner elle
est souvent un facteur qui accompagne
une autre infraction une violence une
insulte une injure la dis passe
quelquefois
à côté de sa prise en compte parce qu'on
prend la fraction principale donc
premièrement savoir vraie il y a un gros
effort encore à faire pour avoir un
tableau de bord mais j'ai lu le rapport
annexé à la Love Me et je vois des
pistes intéressantes deuxièmement parler
vrai
oser poser sur la table et c'est pour ça
que je rend hommage aux deux ministres
et même aux quatre qui nous ont mandatés
ils ont osé dire allez voir la
discrimination y compris commise par la
police donc utiliser les bons mots ce
sont nos propositions 1 2 et 3 y compris
en étant à la disposition du Parlement
et en ce sens je vous remercie
doublement ce président de nous faire
venir c'est nos propositions
4 et 5 les associations proposition 7 et
le fait de ne pas hésiter
à travailler avec les organisations de
défense des droits de l'Homme j'ai un
souvenir lointain quand le ministère de
la Justice
de travailler à un guide de la détention
avec l'oie c'est pas exactement le même
ton c'était le IP il y a 25 ans mais
c'est pas le même temps les productions
de mission de la justice et de l'eau IP
et pourtant
à un moment avait été réussi un guide
commun donc je ne désespère pas qu'il y
ait un travail commun la police et les
organisations de défense des droits
humains peuvent et doivent travailler
ensemble
enfin dans les jurys proposition 11 ça a
commencé déjà l'ouverture des jurys je
sors de trois mois comme vice-président
du jury de l'École nationale de la
magistrature sur sept membres qui
recrutait
260 magistrats il y avait deux
magistrats sur cette
alors on peut penser que c'est pas assez
moi c'est pas mon cas je pense que c'est
très bien que la magistrature soit
recrutée par des personnalités qui
viennent de différents horizons il y
avait un diplomate j'y étais voilà les
points de vue se croisaient et je
souhaite que ce une telle chose se passe
encore plus amplement pour la police
troisièmement qualifier vrai je vous
parlais des nattances il y a une le
droit et donc la police c'est de la
qualification on vous fait entrer dans
une infraction ou pas la définition de
ces infractions et quelque chose de très
important notre proposition
13 pour enregistrer les procédures
notre proposition très et 24 tendent à
revigorer la qualification
discrimination qui est très dissolvante
de de la
de j'aime pas ce terme de vivre ensemble
mais dissolvant de la volonté de vivre
en commun dans une société ordonnée
le quatrième axe répondre vrai mais
quand il y a besoin d'une réponse il
faut la donner et la discrimination ne
peut pas rester sous silence sous le
boisson c'est un peu le thème de notre
rapport ça veut dire un accueillir les
victimes de discrimination j'ai vu que
dans le rapport Love Me et je n'aurais
pas la prétention de penser que c'est la
suite de notre rapport mais j'approuve
dans la loomie les questions de
d'accueil et de confidentialité quand il
y a 15 personnes dans la queue et que
vous êtes obligé de parler de de
violence de violence délicate qui touche
à l'intimité c'est insupportable je l'ai
moi-même
expérimenté en allant de faire une
démarche dans un commissariat de police
les supermarchés prennent une précaution
avec une distance de sécurité ou la SNCF
je pense que la police nationale et la
gendarmerie qui ont pas attendu le
rapport pour aborder sujet mais nous
leur appelons donc accueillir ces les
victimes de discrimination sans les
décourager sans leur poser des questions
indiscrètes
autre que celle nécessitait par
l'enquête proposition 15 et 17
ensuite il est important d'avoir une
réponse interne nous ne sommes pas de
ceux qui disent la justice fera
l'affaire non la première responsabilité
d'un service administratif la police et
la gendarmerie en sont c'est de faire
leur propre police avec une hiérarchie
exemplaire qui s'est détectée les
phénomènes très en amont en nous a cité
l'exemple les documents en main d'un
service ou toutes les fonctionnaires ou
les militaires femmes partent
d'être un grand spécialiste de
déontologie pour comprendre qu'il y a un
problème de rapport de entre les sexes
dans ce service où les femmes sont
peut-être bousculées maltraités voilà
donc ces petits signaux qui les faciles
pour un chef petit ou un grand chef de
ne pas voir nous disons alerte
enfin
quand il y a mis en cause quand il y a
enquête sur un agent on a été sensible
au fait que la gendarmerie
faisait des des comptes à bout d'une
enquête il s'avérait que l'accusation
était mensongère ça vaut aussi au pénal
mais là je parle en disciplinaire et en
organisationnel il y avait des lettres
de mise hors de cause c'est à dire que
l'enquête se terminait on vous laisse
pas planer la suspicion en vous accusait
de discrimination on a fait une enquête
bon le chef dit après enquête bon et
enfin
la réponse disciplinaire et judiciaire
il nous est apparu souvent Florian
Roussel nous en reparlera que
la réaction pouvait être sous
proportionnée à la gravité de
l'infraction on a quelques propositions
en ce sens
je vois que au point de 7 du rapport de
la loopmie il y a quelque chose que nous
n'allions pas jusqu'à proposer c'est
l'exclusion automatique pour certains
délits l'exclusion du service pour
certains délits spécialement dans ceux
qui nous intéresse le racisme et la
discrimination nous disions ça autrement
il faudra mais ça c'est vous le
législateur voir comment une exclusion
automatique de service se met en scène
elle est pas impossible mais mérite
examen très précis enfin
dans l'action disciplinaire puis dans la
saisine du juge article 40 il y a
certainement un progrès pour ne pas
passer de de d'une insuffisance à un
excès de saisine à tout craint de la
justice dès qu'on bouge une oreille mais
une la discrimination c'est la
discrimination ça touche à la dignité
des personnes et appelons les choses par
leur nom transmettons à au pouvoir
disciplinaire à l'enquête
igpn iggn
le la nécessité de réagir enfin je
termine si j'ai encore 3 minutes
monsieur le Président trois minutes pour
m'arrêter une seconde sur le contrôle
d'identité nous ne reprenons pas vous
l'avez vu la thèse développée par
plusieurs organisations et la commission
de consultatif des droits de l'homme du
récépissé parce que après profonde de
réflexion nous pensons que ça aurait ça
n'atteindrait pas le résultat
attendu et que ça créerait
une difficulté dans l'exécution des
tâches en suspectant le policier qui
deviendrait une machine à débiter des
bordereaux mais pour autant nous pensons
que c'est un comme beaucoup de
sociologues que nous avons consulter
Fabien Joba ou ou monsieur Muana par
exemple que c'est un sujet
douloureux à la fois pour le public et
et pas n'importe quel public plutôt des
jeunes de minorités visibles que de gens
comme moi encore que l'autre jour dans
un quai de métro je vois un barrage de
policier de vigiles de la RATP qui
arrêtait des gens et j'avance avec un
petit sourire intérieur en disant voilà
un bourgeois comme moi il va passer
comme une lettre à la poste alors que
les pauvres gamins de 20 ans son
systématiquement arrêtés j'ai progressé
sur mon quai de métro avec une
satisfaction intérieure d'échapper à cet
humiliation et j'ai été le seul à être
arrêté alors que les gamins passaient en
ligne ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir sur
quand même une police républicaine qui
est
mais je dis ça parce que ça m'est arrivé
je n'en tiens évidemment aucune
conclusion si ce n'est qu'il faut jamais
être simple dans ces sujets donc le
récépissé ne nous a pas convaincu mais
nous sentons et nous l'avons dit dans le
rapport et oralement avec les autorités
avec lequel nous travaillons nous
sentons que les choses sont en train
d'être pris en main par la justice et le
contrôle je vous cite pas les décisions
de justice que nous avons mis dans le
rapport mais quand la Cour de cassation
ou la cour d'appel de Paris en 2021
condamnent pour faute lourde l'État pour
contrôle discriminant parce que on
s'aperçoit qu'avec été contrôlé dans une
classe qui revenait de voyage à la gare
du Nord 3 personnes qui appartenaient
aux minorités visibles et pas les autres
attention nous avons dit le il est
évident que les choses sont en train de
changer la police et la gendarmerie
doivent prendre des initiatives d'où
toute une prix de propositions qui
chacune ne peuvent paraître légères ou
pas assez profonde pour celles et ceux
qui connaissent la police et l'âge
gendarmerie si tout ce que nous
proposons étaient mises en œuvre je suis
sûr que le visage du rapport police
population changerait à ce sujet je
recommande la revue après demain de 2020
qui s'appelle qui a été consacré à la
police et à la population dans lequel je
j'écris un article sur la police
peut-elle sourire est-ce que la police
est toujours obligée la gendarmerie
quand elle contrôle de faire comme si
vous aviez déjà tué trois personnes elle
peut contrôler les choses en expliquant
pourquoi elle contrôle d'un mot en et en
ayant un modus opérandit
de calme et de maîtrise voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire aussi rapidement que
possible avant de laisser la parole à
mon co-auteur monsieur Roussel
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je tiens d'abord
à me joindre au président Vigouroux pour
vous remercier de cette invitation à
venir nous exprimer devant vous
aujourd'hui alors pour ma part je vais
exposer trois pistes de réflexion que
nous avons longuement développé dans le
rapport la première qui porte sur
l'évolution des rapports entre les
forces de sécurité intérieure et la
société civile vous en parliez à
l'instant la deuxième qui porte sur
l'évolution du traitement administratif
et disciplinaire des faits de
discrimination commis par les agents et
la troisième sur laquelle je serai plus
rapide qui porte sur une proposition
spécifique au droit pénal
alors sur le premier point le constat
que nous avons dressé dans le rapport
c'est le fait que les relations
s'étaient distendues ces dernières
années entre les forces de police de
gendarmerie tout particulièrement la
police à vrai dire et les représentants
de la société civile
la plupart des principales associations
les avocats les enseignants chercheurs
spécialisés je me rappelle de nos
interlocuteurs qui a parlé de la police
nationale comme une forteresse assiégée
alors les queues sont multiples
il serait trop long de les évoquer ici
mais il nous semble en tout cas que
cette situation n'est pas satisfaisante
c'est évident et nous avons évoqué
plusieurs pistes pour essayer d'y
remédier alors vous avez déjà évoqué
monsieur le Président
de pistes la première qui porte sur
l'élaboration de guides communs entre
l'administration et les associations et
la deuxième également importante à mon
sens sur l'ouverture des jurys de
recrutement
j'ajouterai peut-être trois pistes
supplémentaires de ce point de vue la
première c'est le recours plus fréquent
au référence spécialisés au sein de la
police et de la gendarmerie ils existent
pour certains on pense notamment au
référent LGBT qui travaille à la
préfecture de police que nous avons
rencontré mais peut-être dans certains
dans certaines circonscriptions ne
sont-ils pas suffisamment valorisés
connus etc alors qu'ils peuvent parmi
tous leurs mérites il y a notamment
celui de jouer le rôle d'interlocuteurs
privilégié des associations
ce n'est pas spécifique à la France au
Royaume-Uni notamment c'est on compte
beaucoup sur de telles interlocuteurs et
certaines associations je pense
notamment à une association de défense
des droits des Roms nous ont fait savoir
qu'elles étaient très intéressés par le
fait d'avoir un interlocuteur dédié sur
ces questions donc ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point c'est l'animation
de formation par des représentants
associatifs à destination des forces de
l'ordre alors là encore certaines
existent déjà c'est pas le sujet mais
peut-être devrait-elle être approfondie
à différentes associations
par élire pour les avocats et évoquer
aussi d'autres thèmes de formation je
pense notamment des formations sur les
cultures et les comportements associés
ça existe là encore à l'étranger
notamment en Allemagne et ça permet de
prévenir certaines maladresses ou
certaines formes de stigmatisation lors
des contrôles est plus largement lors
des échanges avec les forces de l'ordre
et les populations concernent et puis
donc il y a cette proposition de
création d'un observatoire des
discriminations
auxquelles serait associée les
représentants associatifs alors il
s'agit de mieux évaluer ce phénomène de
discrimination à travers les carences
que statistique que nous avons pu
observer sur le sujet nous avons essayé
de recouper les signalements
et toutes signalement confondu de
discrimination sur une année nous avons
trouvé 12000 alors que par ailleurs les
enquêtes de victimisation de
victimisation auxquelles vous faisiez
allusion révélé que 7% des plus de 14
ans déclaré au cours des deux dernières
années avoir été victime de
colossal qui montre que il y a
différentes questions mais peut-être
aussi un problème entre autres de
d'évaluation statistique évaluation
d'ailleurs aussi pour le ministère de la
Justice compte tenu des difficultés à
recenser les plaintes sur le sujet
et il importe donc il apparaît important
dans ce cadre que les différents
services mettent en commun leurs
informations échangent entre eux donc
police justice et puis donc en lien avec
les associations afin d'obtenir autant
que possible des données communes
consensuelles sur ce sujet ça c'est la
première piste que je voulais évoquer
la deuxième c'est donc le traitement
administratif est disciplinaire des
faits de discrimination
il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur le sujet
le premier constat que nous avons fait
d'abord c'est que il y a une vraie
volonté de la hiérarchie aujourd'hui je
crois de mieux traiter ces faits de
mieux prendre lorsqu'ils sont constatés
à la fois de faire remonter les
signalements c'est tout l'objet
notamment des plateformes de
signalisation en ligne mais aussi de
mener dans certains cas des
investigations approfondie lorsque des
faits sont constatés et de sanctionner
les coupables
contrairement aux accusations qui ont pu
être parfois proférées il n'y a sûrement
pas d'impunité en la matière alors pour
autant il y a différentes pistes qui
nous paraissent devoir être et analyser
pour adapter encore mieux évoluer encore
plus faire évoluer encore plus cette
réponse disciplinaire
alors ce sont des pistes nous avons bien
sur centré sur notre domaine
d'analyse à savoir la police la
gendarmerie et les discriminations mais
je crois que l'idée c'est que pour
beaucoup ça constait peut-être plus
général au sein de la fonction publique
voilà il s'agit pas de dire que ce n'est
vrai que dans ce domaine précis le
premier c'est que peut-être les mesures
de suspension conservatoire là je parle
en particulier des faits internes au
service n'était pas aussi prononcées
aussi régulièrement qu'elle ne devrait
l'être notamment lorsque l'effets de
harcèlement sexuel par exemple
ont un lourd retentissement
psychologique pour les victimes
pourraient s'attendre à ce que soit plus
nombreuse et dans les dans les dossiers
individuels que nous avons consulté nous
sommes parfois étonnés qu'elle n'était
pas été plus régulièrement prononcée
de même vous y faisiez allusion nous
nous sommes étonnés du fait que les
signalements au parquet étaient aussi
peu fréquents alors que dans bien des
cas l'effet de discrimination constitue
très souvent des crimes ou des délits
donc qui doivent être signaler à
l'autorité judiciaire
à l'inverse
lorsqu'il y a une procédure pénale qui a
été engagée à la demande de la victime
il est parfois regrettable que
l'administration
attendent l'issue de cette procédure
pour engager des poursuites
disciplinaires alors qu'on pourrait
penser que les deux procédures doivent
aller de pair il y a pas besoin
d'attendre que le pénal tienne le
disciplinaire en l'état ça va pour la
police mais ça pourrait valoir pour
beaucoup d'autres administrations
quatrième point spécifique sa porte sur
les écoles de formation des policiers
des gendarmes nous avons parfois relevé
dans des dossiers des faits assez
sérieux le discrimination et nous nous
sommes étonnés de la réponse qui avait
été faite
dans certains cas il faut on pouvait
s'étonner qu'il n'y ait pas eu de mesure
d'exclusion définitive lorsque les faits
révélé une inaptitude de l'élève a
exercé les fonctions alors ça j'ai pas
de dire que c'est général mais nous
avons retrouvé plusieurs cas précis ou
vu des données dont on disposées on
pouvait sérieusement sur le sujet
plus généralement dans certains nombre
dans un certain nombre de dossiers nous
nous sommes là encore interrogés sur la
réponse qui avait été apporté des fois
un simple rappel à la loi alors que
l'effet du discrimination par PC assez
sérieux dans d'autres une sanctions qui
n'étaient peut-être pas aussi lourde
qu'elle aurait pu peut-être être vu des
données qui nous avait été communiqués
alors nous citons quelques exemples
précis dans le dans le rapport
j'assisterai peut-être sur un point très
précis sur ce point ça m'a frappé pour
les discriminations internes au service
c'est que bien des fois c'est la victime
elle-même la victime des faits de
discrimination lorsque c'est un agent
qui a dû obtenir sa mutation qui a dû
partir ailleurs dans une autre
circonscription de police l'auteur des
faits parfois il a été sanctionné et
c'est très bien mais lui il est resté en
fonction il est resté à son poste le
message envoyé n'est peut-être pas
satisfaisant
alors en ce qui concerne les faits de
discrimination cette fois-ci commis à
l'égardière ce même constat général peut
aussi j'ajouterai peut-être trois points
précis le premier c'est le traitement
des signalements alors les signalements
parfois ils sont directement gérés par
les
circonscriptions de police au niveau de
chaque circonscription c'est normal ils
sont nombreux dans certains cas nous
avons cité des exemples qui venaient des
procédures elles-mêmes que nous avions
consulté nous ne sommes étonnés d'un
traitement parfois très succinct très
rapide alors que les faits qui étaient
remontés étaient assez précis et à tout
le moins dans la réponse voilà lorsque
il y a des faits bien et circonstancié
on ne peut pas se contenter de répondre
que
la remarque
est trop succincte et surtout lorsque la
plainte fait état d'un jeu raciste et
antisémite lors d'un contrôle d'un
contrôle de police on ne peut pas se
contenter de répondre comme nous l'avons
vu parfois ah bah oui mais le contrôle
était justifié vous étiez en infraction
donc de la route ça priori ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas acceptable d'autres
réponses ont pu nous sembler maladroites
notamment par rapport à certains cas de
d'accusation d'un jour homophobe
exactement
à droite et dans d'autres elle nous a
paru minimiser la réalité des
alors sur les signalements j'ajoute un
point c'est le traitement des
signalements par le Défenseur des droits
donc on va pas revenir sur tous les
procédures enfin nous avons comptabilisé
36 signalements en quelques années de la
part du Défenseur des droits sur ce
sujet aucun n'a donné lieu à des
poursuites disciplinaires ça paru
étrange alors que pour les procédures
que l'on a vu sans vouloir porter un
jugement définitif dans certains cas il
y avait quand même des éléments
et dernier point la problématique des
lanceurs d'alerte qu'il ne faut pas non
plus sous-estimer
dans certains cas le lanceur d'alerte on
lui reprochait à lui aussi certains
faits et donc dans ces cas-là est
logique qu'ils doivent aussi qu'il soit
aussi poursuivis sur le plan
disciplinaire dans certains cas je pense
à deux d'entre eux en particulier nous
nous sommes étonnés que la sanction que
le traitement administratif qui avait
été réservé lanceur d'alerte avait plus
nous sembler plus sévères que celui qui
avait été réservé aux personnes qui
dénoncent cela nous a interrogé
dernier point très brièvement
l'adaptation du droit pénal
nous avons fait une proposition
principale voilà qui que sur laquelle je
reviendrai brièvement elle porte sur
l'injure non public commise par les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique alors actuellement c'est un
jour non public pour toute personne
un policier comme moi vous c'est
simplement une contravention de
cinquième classe qui est punie de 1500
euros d'amende lorsque l'injure
République cela devient un déni qui est
possible d'un an de prison 45000 euros
d'amende alors le distinguo public non
public est très subtil il y a une
jurisprudence très développée de la Cour
de cassation je n'y reviens pas mais
lorsqu'il s'agit d'acte commis par des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique cette distinction n'apparaît
pas toujours pertinente est-ce qu'il est
plus grave de proférer une injure
raciste dans la quand on est policier
dans la rue ou dans le fourgon dans le
fourgon de police par exemple
pourrait penser que les deux faits
appellent la même réponse pénale de même
la presse s'est fait l'écho ces
dernières années de plusieurs affaires
assez lourdes portant sur des injures
racistes antisémites répétés sur les
réseaux sociaux
avec un fort retentissement une forte
atteinte aussi à l'image de
l'institution et puis parfois des
sanctions disciples minéraux lourdes
même parfois la révocation et c'est fait
n'ont pourtant donné lieu qu'à une
poursuite devant le tribunal de police
pour une simple contravention alors même
que à la fois il y avait une vraie
atteinte à l'image de l'institution une
vraie atteinte au devoir d'exemplarité
de l'agent et puis enfin on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser que lorsque les
faits sont commis les mêmes faits
d'injures non public sont commis à le
contre à l'encontre d'une personne
dépositaires de l'autorité publique cela
devient attrait juste titre un délit
donc on peut penser que la réciproque
devrait être vrai aussi donc voilà
quelques brièvement exposés quelques
l'une des propositions de notre rapport
et maintenant je crois que nous sommes à
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci
merci Monsieur Roussel bien merci pour
cette présentation il y a plusieurs
collègues qui souhaitent intervenir le
premier d'entre eux étant Monsieur
Jérôme Durand puis Monsieur Alain Marc
Madame Brigitte l'airbier et puis madame
benbassac qui vient de
monsieur Durand merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais chaleureux
remercier au nom de mon groupe
messieurs vigou et Roussel pour
le caractère de vérité la tonalité de
leur discours la tonalité du rapport qui
est très éclairant et qui à la fois
courageux libre et qui pose des mots
justes sur des réalités qui sont
complexes et vous n'avez pas minimiser
la complexité dans votre propre
luminaire
et puis on remercie aussi le président
de la commission des lois qui a ouvert
droit à notre demande de d'audition
parce qu'il nous semble que ce rapport
qu'on a d'abord découvert par Mediapart
avant que le ministère de l'Intérieur de
le rendre public peut-être aurait-il
fallu d'ailleurs que ce soit l'inverse
nous a paru justifier si intéressent
ce rapport il est dense il est riche il
est quasi exhaustif et puis il permet de
dépasser un certain nombre de sujets qui
nous tiennent vraiment à coeur dans le
groupe que auquel j'appartiens sur
rapport police population qui qui est au
cœur des des questions de fonctionnement
de la police républicaine des tiques la
police peut-elle sourire je trouve que
la formule est très juste et renvoie les
réalités qui nous marquent chacun alors
notre groupe avait défendu l'idée qu'on
pouvait
faire de
ces discriminations subies ou commises
par les forces de sécurité un indicateur
de performance budgétaire une secrétaire
d'état depuis démissionnaires avait
répondu
en séance c'est pas utile c'est déjà
dans les rapports igpn et iggn c'est pas
le cas et puis en plus ça n'a pas la
même portée notre collègue Dominati
avait donné un avis favorable pour la
commission des finances sur la création
de cet indicateur budgétaire on le
remercie donc l'amendement était passé
le ministre de l'Intérieur avait dit
qu'il était souhaitable que que ce
rapport puis cette indicateur puisse
être créé
est-ce que si on arrive à obtenir gain
de cause ce sera grâce à votre rapport
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner les
difficultés chez Vigouroux que vous avez
rencontré concernant le manque de
statistiques justement la matière et
comment on peut on peut approfondir un
peu ces données pour que elle soit utile
politiquement deuxième question que
j'avais à vous poser concerne les
contrôles d'identité vous avez écarté le
récépissé peut-être nous dire en deux
trois mots pourquoi
peut-être à l'aide de pas besoin
international et puis en séance on nous
avait indiqué une ministre aux banques
qui avait une mission de la Cour des
comptes sur le les contrôles d'identité
est-ce que vous avez connaissance de ce
sujet merci merci monsieur Durand
monsieur Marc
merci Président
vous avez évoqué monsieur le rapporteurs
les rapports entre ou du moins la
perception de la population par rapport
à sa police et à son gendarmerie et la
distinction qu'il y avait
entre entre les deux effectivement ces
rapports se sont distendus nous
sénateurs qui sommes sur le terrain
n'est-ce pas et qui donc voyons à chaque
inspection de brigades annonce et à
chaque sainte Geneviève on ressent quand
même les efforts que font actuellement
les commandants de groupement sous la
direction du DGGN mais aussi pour ce qui
concerne la police des efforts qui sont
faits effectivement pour aller au plus
près des citoyens de façon à ce que ceci
est une meilleure perception de la
police et de leur gendarmerie d'autre
part vous savez que la qualité du
renseignement français qui était un de
nos fleurons il y a de cela quelques
dizaines d'années là aussi c'était
estompé parce que ce rapport justement
entre la police gendarmerie et la
population étaient distendue et qu'il
convient me semble-t-il d'ailleurs pour
la pour la qualité de notre police et
notre gendarmerie que celui-ci sera
Fermi donc des instructions me
semble-t-il sont donnés en ce sens je ne
sais pas si vous avez pu le mesurer
d'autre part lorsque l'on a des
discriminations
supposées entre
les policiers les gendarmes et la
population notamment lors
d'interpellation ou de contrôle
d'identité un de nos collègues et nous
avons je crois ici apporter notre part à
cela c'est nous qui avons
préconisé les caméras piétons et
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez pu
évaluer leur efficacité aussi du moins
dans votre rapport vous préconisez
d'évaluer l'efficacité de ces dernières
et qui nous semblent être quelque chose
de positif
merci Monsieur Marc madame l'herbier
écho venir sur ce que disait monsieur
figuru en amont de tout ça l'intérêt de
développer la mixité
comme
la paix publique
au sein de la police
vous savez je suis élu depuis très
longtemps sur la zone Roubaix Tourcoing
et je suis universitaire et à ce titre
j'ai rencontré
un jeune à l'époque et une vingtaine
d'années il s'appelait Abel Kader Haroun
c'est actuellement le commissaire
général de police de Roubaix et alors
Kader Haroun et le portrait type de
quelqu'un qui aurait pu déraper comme
beaucoup de jeunes de banlieue et qui
s'est raccroché à la police pour évoluer
pour se construire et pour construire
toute une famille il a créé les chemins
de la réussite c'est une association qui
aide les enfants et les jeunes qui se
sentent discriminés dans le cadre de
leurs études pour les aider à évoluer et
à accéder
tous les concours magistrats policiers
enfin tout ce qui existe comme concours
et leur dernièrement les mois dernier on
a organisé ensemble un col
au sein de la mairie de Tourcoing où on
a reçu les témoignages des jeunes qui
étaient rentrés dans la police beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes d'origine maghrébine
d'origine de ZUP de classe sociale
défavorisées et ces jeunes étaient très
fiers d'être dans la police et plein de
d'espérance et de confiance en la police
et quand vous entendiez leur témoignage
on se disait quand même la police
comme la gendarmerie comme comme la
magistrature c'est vraiment une
possibilité mais surtout la police dans
ce cadre là un ascenseur social tous les
jeunes qui se sont exprimés de toute
évidence ils avaient dû passer de
nombreux États avant d'arriver
à leur
à leur poste de policiers même de base
juste un poste plus conséquent dans la
police alors tous ces témoignages
m'ont fait beaucoup réfléchir je me suis
rendu compte et de façon dans le cadre
professionnel universitaire je m'en
rendais déjà compte c'était très
difficile pour eux de trouver des stages
et on a créé un tutorat avec Kader Harun
pour les épauler justement à quitter le
monde difficile
pour accéder à une espérance et de
rentrer dans la police
la seule chose que je voulais je voulais
insister là-dessus c'est que forcément
il risque d'avoir des discriminations
ces jeunes parce qu'ils viennent de ces
quartiers les autres qui n'arrivent pas
s'en échapper forcément ils les ont en
cible souvent ce des cibles verbal ça va
pas beaucoup plus loin pour l'instant
beaucoup de cibles verbales et
certainement des discriminations en
disant vendu enfin vous voyez tout ce
qu'on peut pourraient leur reprocher
et je pense que l'école de police de
Roubaix en a pris acte et ils font très
attention
à épauler les policiers dans le cadre
d'une réaction potentielle et parce que
comment les degrés de réaction qui
peuvent avoir face à leurs jeunes qui
étaient juste avant leur copains de
virer pas toujours très positive alors
ce que j'ai remarqué aussi mais
j'attends de vous de confirmation ou pas
dans la gendarmerie je pense que on a
moins de de
réactions comme ça de parce que en
caserne ils sont plus encadrés dès le
départ tout jeune les jeunes qui
arrivent à la gendarmerie ils ont une un
encadrement très vigilant et qui évite
justement
de les laisser tout seul face à une
réaction voilà c'est ce que c'est
surtout là-dessus que je voulais revenir
et dans la magistrature c'est pareil
vous vous disiez aussi monsieur
Vigouroux que les jurys il fallait
élargir
le chant et moi je rajouterai aussi une
chose dans le cadre de
des concours évitez de mettre des des
matières qui ne correspondent pas à
leurs origines je m'explique par exemple
si dans la magistrature vous développez
à outrance la culture générale ces
jeunes ils n'ont pas de culture générale
de base et c'est très difficile pour eux
en deux ans de temps de récupérer tout
le passé d'une famille qui a été
encadrante pour les autres voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire et je vous remercie
les uns et les autres d'avoir abordé ce
sujet merci
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
vous remercier pour ce rapport très
instructif et je voudrais faire quelques
remarques
concernant le contrôle au facièse mes
collègues ont déjà
fait des remarques à ce sujet mais
j'avais déposé un texte en 2014 sur ce
sujet et je constate qu'il n'y a pas eu
une grande évolution pourtant on a eu
des travaux que vous avez cités de
Jobard Lévy et les vies etc etc
j'oublierai une parenthèse si on regarde
les chiffres donnés vous êtes enfin ne
sont pas nombreux les bourgeois blanc
arrêté n'est-ce pas très très rare quand
on regarde ces statistiques et depuis
ces travaux qui ont été quand même
complétés par des Américains qui ont
fait aussi un travail dans ce sens et je
ne vois pas d'évolution les caméras ou
pas laisser pisser ou pas il y a eu des
expériences comme vous le savez en
Espagne dans une région il y a eu
n'est-ce pas il y a eu d'autres
expériences et aux États-Unis au Canada
il y a des expériences dans ce sens et
ce qu'on pourrait pas s'en inspirer et
arrêter ce facteur de discrimination et
qui est quand même insupportable surtout
qu'aujourd'hui avec le mouvement wok et
d'autres c'est disons ces contrôles de
faciès deviennent encore plus
insupportable et il faut il faut quand
même concéder c'est vraiment
insupportable des gens qui se font
arrêter plusieurs fois par jour parfois
etc et vous avez parlé très brièvement
de la formation et c'est vrai que nous
nous recevons d'une part et du courrier
des élèves de ces formations des femmes
surtout qui se plaignent une femme
maghrébine ou issue
disons issu de l'immigration et disons
combien
elles sont sujettes à des
discriminations et la liste est bien
longue mais assez classique et je pense
que on n'a pas je me suis intéressé
moins que vous mais un peu on manque
d'heures de formation le nombre d'heures
de formation aux discriminations et aux
racisme dans ces écoles et n'est pas
assez importante
à ces importants et ensuite il faudrait
aussi faire faire faire des stages de
formation en faisant venir des experts
quand même parce que il faut renouveler
le la perception par la population de la
discrimination n'est-ce pas ce n'est pas
toujours la même avec l'évolution
actuelle et en même temps
je serai très utile qu'il voit comment
se George de de lutte contre les
discriminations se déroulent dans
d'autres pays comme par exemple en
Allemagne et aux États-Unis voilà merci
beaucoup merci Madame
et bien oui
merci à merci à tous les deux pour la
qualité de vos travaux merci au
président buffet d'avoir permis cette
audition qui qui semble nous avoir tous
beaucoup intéressé
je voudrais revenir sur sur l'ensemble
de l'utilité de ces travaux
lorsque nous avons interrogé le ministre
de l'Intérieur dans cette salle
d'ailleurs c'était Jérôme Durin qui
l'avait interrogé il nous a dit je cite
je suis très favorable conclusion du
rapport de Christian vigou déontologue
du ministère d'intérieur sur les actes
et propos racistes et discriminants au
sein de la police et je suis favorable
au changement je suis donc prêt à
travailler sur des amendements sur le
sujet par exemple dans la locmie il a
évoqué le fait que ce rapport ne
proposait pas le récépissé pour le
contrôle d'identité
il a annoncé qu'il rendrait public ce
rapport et qu'il fallait avancer sur ce
sujet donc ma question elle est très
simple
quels sont les suites qui ont été donnés
à ces travaux puisque ces travaux sont
désormais un peu anciens
merci Monsieur tenue avec Salim
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur pour
vous vous développements je voulais
juste savoir si votre rapport a concerné
les outre-mer
ou la problématique des discriminations
existent et notamment une spécifique en
tout cas qui est vécu comme tel par les
intéressés
s'agissant du retour des originaires
comme on dit dans la police dans la
gendarmerie voir dans le pénitentiaire
les originaires lorsqu'ils sont mutés en
métropole et qu'ils cherchent à revenir
dans les territoires d'outre-mer et
beaucoup nous saisissent parce qu'ils
vivent
leur situation de nos retours en tout
cas dans l'immédiat comme une
discrimination
merci à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur
Roussel dans l'ordre que vous
souhaiterez
on va alterner
d'abord dans l'ordre de des prises de
parole dire à Monsieur Durin que
je dis une fois pour toute pour pas
avoir à le répéter malgré toute l'envie
que j'en ai je suis pas encore ministre
de l'Intérieur donc très sérieusement
les indices les les indicateurs c'est
très important et moi à titre personnel
puisque c'est uniquement ça que nous
pouvons faire
il nous semble dans l'optique de ce que
j'ai dit de qualifier et de mesurer et
de parler vrai
tout indicateur possible y compris dans
les papes et les documents budgétaires
puisque depuis l'annonce c'est bien de
ça qu'il s'agit c'est de mesurer la
performance et bien dans un service de
force de sécurité c'est un élément de
performance la maîtrise de la Force et
de l'autorité parce que discrimination
c'est ça maîtriser la force sans jamais
empiéter sur la dignité de la personne
et bien c'est le cœur du métier de
police et si on trouvait un indicateur
moi je ou plusieurs indicateurs exemple
le taux de protestation c'est pour ça
que on
vante vraiment un travail statistique
je serai je pense que ce serait très
très
utile
les efforts fait en matière de
statistiques date depuis longtemps il a
fallu des années pour que le ministère
de l'Intérieur et ministère de la
Justice et des professionnels des
caractéristiques à la tête de leurs
services de statistiques il y a peu de
temps que c'est des inspecteurs général
de l'Insee qui sont d'un côté comme de
l'autre c'est une évolution que certains
ont voulu depuis des années on y est
donc je suis raisonnablement optimiste
mais les statistiques qualifiées en
matière de discrimination et on a
demandé dans le rapport que l'on
affine les distinctions qu'on comprenne
plus la discrimination dans un bloc
unique pour
Monsieur Marc sur la police et la
gendarmerie je vais laisser la parole à
Florian Roussel puis je dirais un mois
après
merci donc sur le sur cette réponse à
votre question monsieur le sénateur deux
points d'abord sur donc les le souci de
la police et de la gendarmerie d'aller
au contact de la population nous avons
trouvé même exemple j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure les difficultés en lien avec les
relations entre les représentants
d'association il revient pas mais dans
le sens que vous évoquez il y a eu de
nombreux il y a eu de nombreuses
initiatives qui ont été prises alors au
niveau institutionnel d'abord les
partenariats opérationnels etc donc les
relations avec les élus mais aussi au
niveau du terrain au niveau des
intéressés eux-mêmes j'ai le souvenir en
particulier un échange très instructif
que nous avions eu avec le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique du
Nord qui nous avait longuement
insisté sur son souci donc de le fait
qu'il reliait systématiquement à ces
agents le souci de à chaque fois prendre
contact avec sociaux avec les avec les
différentes avec les commerçants enfin
que la population que la police soit
vraiment en contact de la population que
les différents signaux faibles de
problèmes illus soient très vite relayés
et donc oui il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives locales qui sont
encouragés au niveau national de ce
point de vue et je crois que c'est
important encore une fois aussi bien
dans la police que dans la que dans la
gendarmerie sur les caméras piétons
alors notre rapport est intervenu à un
moment très précis c'est au moment où le
nouveau dispositif de caméra venait à
être décidé fenêtre Mise en oeuvre donc
on en a pas vu les résultats puisque
c'est à partir de juillet 2021 je crois
que on a pu on a pu le tester ce dont
nous avons été témoin par contre c'est
des très fortes attentes des policiers
des gendarmes sur le sujet il y avait
une vraie
tout se déplorer la qualité très très
insuffisante du système ancien et tous
espéré vraiment que ces caméras
permettraient
leur serait très utile et la fois pour
se défendre lorsqu'ils sont mis en cause
pour des faits de discrimination et à la
fois pas pour voilà pour
identifier les pour les protéger même
lorsqu'ils sont lorsqu'ils sont prêts à
partir donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
temps mais je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus sur savoir si ses attentes ont été
ou non satismes sur les caméras piétons
il y a plusieurs questions celui qui
vous parle il se trouve est président du
comité d'éthique de la vidéo
surveillance à Paris donc ça fait deux
ans que j'essaie avec toute une ensemble
de personnalités de faire que ce
dispositif ne déborde pas n'aillent pas
au-delà de ce pourquoi il est fait donc
c'est une question qui m'intéresse les
caméras piétons que nous avons
chaleureusement recommandé et fleurs
Roussel a raison de dire que les
policiers attendent ça il y a quand même
quelques questions qui se posent qui
informent que vous êtes filmé moi si je
suis contrôlé je
inspiré que de savoir que je suis filmé
et je serai un peu révolté si je ne sais
pas donc là je suis pas sûr qu'un
formation madame monsieur qui contrôlait
vous êtes filmé soit toujours
suffisamment donné deuxièmement qui
allume est-ce que c'est en constant à
l'image ou est-ce qu'on allume à
l'initiative du policier que dans le
fait du contrôle troisièmement qui est
un parce que ça arrive que un policier
le ton monte et il préfère éteindre donc
et qui conserve et qui concerne pendant
pourquoi on conserve-t-elle opération
telle caméra tel film de telle opération
et qu'on a fait disparaître tel film de
tel autre opération donc nous
recommandons cette technique mais ça
mérite examen
et mais ça peut quand même créer un
effet quand la personne en face du
policier est informée qu'elle est filmée
tous les praticiens nous disent que le
temps n'est plus tout à fait le même
c'est ce qu'on prend en cible à Madame
l'herbier je voudrais dire que
l'expérience de Roubaix nous intéresse
c'est bien l'esprit que nous faisons
j'ai dit je n'y reviens pas que une
police ou une gendarmerie qui ressemble
à la population c'est nécessaire
spécialement en outre-mer monsieur le
sénateur mais en même temps il faut pas
commencer à faire des exclusions à
contrario parce que vous rentrez pas
dans les schémas des pourcentages moi je
n'emploie jamais le terme discrimination
positive mais par contre aller chercher
et c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup
d'intérêt à ce que vous avez dit allez
chercher comme un Sud le faire la
Troisième République ces élites tous ces
cadres dans des populations qui n'y
pensaient absolument pas et chacun en a
dans nos dans nos ancêtres même récents
des gens qui ont qui sont allés dans les
carrières de service public au prix de
sécurité parce qu'on est allé les
chercher il suffit pas d'être dans son
fauteuil d'attendre les candidatures
donc ce que vous avez dit je me permets
de dire que c'est tout à dans l'esprit
de ce que nous ce que nous cherchons
[Musique]
le alors le fondamental je l'ai vu
encore pendant trois mois pour la
magistrature mais j'extrapole pour la
police qui est notre sujet monsieur le
Président ce qu'on appelle pompeusement
les biais cognitifs évidemment à
certains candidats que j'ai passé donc
c'est ces trois derniers mois si on leur
demandait le
dernier livre d'un auteur connu ils
étaient secs alors que sur les mangas ou
sur
tel autre production de grand public
actuels ils étaient incollables alors si
on refuse absolument ceux qui ne
connaissent pas Giraudoux dans les tous
les sens et qui nous bassine avec les
mangas effectivement la République se
portera mal donc les jurys la diversité
des jurys est l'orientation non pas vers
une série de connaissances qui doivent
avoir en matière de droit et pas de
doute mais pas seulement les
connaissances mais aussi du jugement du
respect des gens et ça ça se mesure dans
les concours nous sommes c'est ce que
nous avons essayé de dire dans le
rapport
et enfin
enfin
Madame de La Gontrie ça serait bien un
prétentieux de dire que il y a déjà des
suites mais
il me semble que dans certains
dans certains
positions prises par le rapport de la
locmi ce qui est la décision la plus
récente c'est là que vous avez j'ai
retrouvé une série de choses qui vont
enfin dans lequel je me retrouve c'est
simplement une appréciation après
peut-être que je me trompe mais
le parcours de la victime page 60
ce que j'ai dit qui est délicat mais
nécessaire le fait que la police se
ressemble
relativement sans trop de dichotomie à
la population la formation alors le
rapport de la Cour des comptes
quand on a écrit le rapport je peux pas
en dire grand chose si ce n'est que
c'est très bien que la Cour des comptes
s'occupe de la formation des policiers
qu'il faut
rallonger surtout en formation continue
je crois beaucoup à la formation à
l'école ouverte aux organisations de
défense des droits humains pourquoi la
Ligue des droits de l'homme pourquoi
SOS racines ne viendrait pas rencontrer
les policiers c'est ça fait partie les
uns et les autres font partie de la
société et il y a des expériences en ce
sens dont on me police le les caméras
piétons embarquées en a parlé il faut
faire attention aussi à
ne pas
prendre sans précaution les outils
technologiques comme les drones très
qualifiés pour donc pour m'occuper de la
ville de Paris les nouveaux modes de
caméra sont quand même assez saisissant
à tous les sens du mot on peut voir on
peut lire le livre que une personne lit
à une terrasse de café avec une caméra
qui est à 50 mètres donc
les caméras embarquées en tout cas c'est
un moyen de pacifier le contact immédiat
entre la personne contrôlée le
paragraphe de 5.3 de la locmi sur la
lutte contre les discriminations le
[Musique]
collège de déontologie qui est créée
l'exclusion comme je l'ai dit du service
ça va dans le sens de ce que Florian
Roussel vous rappelait sur le fait qu'on
a trouvé quelques fois que les sanctions
j'y vais avec prudence parce que pour
exercer le pouvoir disciplinaire c'est
que c'est pas si simple enfin on
pourrait quand même
sans aller sur l'exclusion à tout coup
dire que quelqu'un qui a réitéré de la
discrimination il est pas fait pour la
police ou la gendarmerie la
prise en compte des questions
particulières à l'Outre-mer page 93 du
rapport que qui est joint à la loi que
vous avez adopté nous avons passé un
moment nous avons voulu aller discuter
notamment avec la centrale outre-mer de
la gendarmerie nationale c'est-à-dire le
général qui s'occupe des et c'est vrai
que le pourcentage de force de la
gendarmerie en outre pose question
peut-être que quand il faut ramener la
paix comme un Mayotte l'autre jour il
faut des forces de sécurité mais dans le
temps long je trouve que ça interroge
quand même dans le rapport entre la
sécurité et les populations d'outre-mer
qu'une part non négligeable des forces
notamment mobiles de la gendarmerie soit
en outre-mer et le rapport de la locmi
qui parle de prépositionner des forces
en outre-mer va plutôt dans le sens
encore alors moi je considère que les
forces mobiles qui sont pas si
nombreuses que ça dans le pays doivent
être utilisés que quand on ne peut pas
faire autrement c'est des forces
d'intervention donc je pense qu'il y a
une nous en nous en avons parlé dans le
rapport le rapport de la locmi aborde le
sujet et c'est bien il y a un sujet
particulier à traiter à traiter ici
je vais certainement pas répondu à
toutes les questions mais
je note aussi que quand je vois cette
image
qui est une affiche sur les différents
types de discriminations que ministère
d'intérieur a développé avant notre
rapport je sais pas de tout ramener aux
effets du rapport qui est les 24
critères de discrimination pour avoir le
label Diversité discrimination de la
fnor c'est pas c'est pas moi 15 ans il y
a ça je trouve que c'est c'est pour
avoir d'autres temps militaires et
obtenu que la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme soit affichée d'une part dans
les commissariats d'autre part dans les
prisons je pense que un affichage comme
ça qui dit les différents modes de
discrimination est utile parce que quand
on a fait une enquête au Conseil d'État
ça nous éloigne de la police mais enfin
nous connaissons bien cette maison tous
les deux sur les sujets de
discrimination au Conseil d'État dans le
personnel et les collègues les deux
motifs de discrimination majeure ils
sont là c'est c'était l'âge et
l'apparence physique on s'attend pas à
ce que il y en a pas donc
il y a tout là et ça peut faire
réfléchir les fonctionnaires
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur Roussel de votre venue ce
matin et merci aux collègues évidemment
d'avoir assisté et poser des questions
[Musique]